there is a lot of
a lot of gun violence a lot of gangs and
um you had to
his here's the thing that i say a lot of
people always say oh
you know well you had a choice you had a
choice you you had a choice you don't
have a choice
if you grow up in the kind of projects
you don't really have a choice because
this is how it goes
let's say there's always more than one
gang right
they can be three they can be four they
can be one they can be two whatever
um in my projects it was like three or
four right
so think about it if you're a kid
growing up in the projects right
and there are three or four gangs that
are in that projects right
what do you think is going to happen to
you if you don't join one
you're gonna get your ass kicked from
all four right so at least
if you become part of something then you
have protection from the other things
so it's it it's not something that you
can say that you have a choice
because you really don't have a choice
right so
you know you join a gang and you become
part of
uh the gang becomes part of your fam
well they become your family
they become you and you know and they
become more important than
your family so that was kind of my
situation
wow so were a lot of your friends and a
lot of people that you knew they were
all in gangs
yeah yeah like all my friends like all
my friends
i didn't have normal friends and anyone
who's normal i didn't like them
so i i already and then what happens i
already developed
like just the hatred for people in
general like really
yeah as a kid i just didn't like
i just was i was an angry kid so i was
always looking
for uh some fuel to to piss me off to do
something
you know i was i was really crazy and
just not normal by any means
you're telling me that story about your
mom and the bike some kid stole your
bike oh yeah yeah
i told you that story yeah you told me
that on the phone oh my god that's crazy
because i don't tell most people that
story really
yeah it's a so that story is crazy
you're actually the only person who's
ever heard that story as a
as a podcast or on any show ever really
so that's crazy i tell you a story but
yeah today's my lucky day that's crazy
uh but yeah so um i remember when
i think i came in with how young i was i
was definitely very young
and i had a bike and i was downstairs
and um
some kid took my bike like he told me
let me
let him ride it let him ride it kid
wouldn't give it back and i went
upstairs crying
and my mom how old were you i i don't i
i want to say i want to say 10 let's
just say it's got to be 10. it's got to
be really young
because by 13 i would have just like
it wouldn't have been good but uh but
yeah it had to be like nine
nine like nine or ten and i came
upstairs crying
and my mom told me she says listen if
you don't go back downstairs
and get that bike i'm gonna kick your
ass all over this place
and i was like whoa and my mom my mom
was no joke like my mom would hurt you
for real so
i was more scared of my mom i went
downstairs the kid
and the kid's still there and like
literally punched him in the face
and he started crying i took my bike
went back upstairs and then my mom said
good job yeah
that's great wow but this is the same
mom who also
said hey you know you shouldn't be out
there fighting so
well i mean that was probably good for
you in a way yeah do that i mean that
was a pretty good lesson she taught you
that was a really young age especially
living in that part
in that in that kind of town you know
what i mean in new york yeah
you got to be tough when you're young to
be able to be able to survive and be
able to make it right yeah
you do you do you do i mean if if
if you're not then people people will
try to take advantage of you or
you know people people judge you a lot
just by the way
by the way your your your face looks or
or by the way your demeanor is so
there's a lot of times you'll see people
walking around
with this face like you know like like
this
but that might not even be really that
you know that might not be their heart
that might not even be where they're at
but a lot of times
they know that if they're not like that
then people are going to say oh yo you
know what yeah that dude's soft yo
let's get him you know something like
that so a lot of people walk around you
know try to be like yo i'm hard i'm hard
i'm hard
like i've got into some crazy some some
crazy just crazy stuff
in terms of that kind of thing where
where
uh particularly injured any of them
a particular individual was trying to be
hard
and uh put a gun to my face
and i slapped the [ __ ] out of him
dropped the gun
tried to shoot him and guess what he had
no bullets in the gun
so he dropped his gun and you picked it
up
it was crazy it happened in the club and
he
it's a long story had to do with a girl
and him talking nonsense i was with my
boys and
and and you know and another thing when
you're with your gang
you you you feel like superman
it doesn't matter like you're all
powerful and and and this this this uh
feeling because your boy's got your back
and
you i can't explain it but it's just
such a powerful feeling
and this this this kid put a gun to my
face was talking [ __ ] about
in a nightclub outside outside nightclub
about
about his girl whatever whatever and and
i just got pissed off
i just [ __ ] backslapped him like as
hard as i can
and he dropped the gun on the floor and
then i picked it up
and guess what it had no [ __ ] bullets
in it
so he's walking around with a gun with
no bullets right
zero bullets and i've encountered a lot
of i've accounted a lot of that kind of
stuff
in my life where where where where
you know people try to present
themselves as something
that they're not i mean it's happened
another time too when i was with one of
my closest
friends was in my gang and the kid came
up to us
you know we were walking the kids
looking at us and we just looked at them
then they walked away and then they
started coming back and i told my boy yo
we we're gonna have to fight right now
because these [ __ ] coming back
they started coming back towards us and
all it was was
oh why are you looking at us how do you
know we're looking at you if you're not
looking at us
you know some real dumbness and then the
kid was just talking to the kid pull out
a gun
and you know one of his friends at the
time i had his name called tragedy like
that was my gang name tragedy they
called you tragedy
why they call you that because if you
mess with me it was going to be a
tragedy for you
but that was my name it was it was
tragedy so so
and then one of the kids was like yo i
think tragedy knows your brother
because this kid's brother was a
gangster and his brother was in jail and
then
it so happened that that um they figured
out that
we knew each other and then the kid
kind of like it's alright whatever and
he left it alone
but i wasn't gonna leave it alone
because [ __ ] just pulled a gun
on me
so a few days later i was with my boy
and we this is during high school and we
saw him
and my boy's like yo that's the kid from
the day right there
so i was like worried so i got my other
two boys and we went and followed him
and he went into a store
and i went into the store and i someone
said yo yo remember me yeah let's talk i
want to talk to you right
and i wasn't going to do nothing to him
but i just wanted to make a point i
would
i was always about making a point so he
didn't want to come out the store
and i was like no just come out i said
don't worry no one's packing anything i
always want to talk to you just come out
just come out so so he finally came out
the store and i was like yo
you remember the other day you put a gun
in my you put a gun in my face
i said yo if you put a gun in somebody's
face then you better use it
i said don't put a gun in somebody's
face and then don't use that [ __ ] cause
right now
i could just end your life right now if
i wanted to right
so i i told him i says you know i got
respect for your brother
but what what you want to do you want to
keep this or you want to end this
how you want to do it and then he just
chose to just just squash it so we
squashed it
but you know like i said there's a lot
of there's a lot of
kind of those kind of things going
around where people
you know want to be that gangster but
they're not really that gangster yeah
was there i mean
was there a lot of gun violence being
involved with those gangs you see a lot
of people getting shot all the time like
like i i've had friends who's gotten
shot in front of me
you know i've gotten graced twice gotten
what grazed grazed
oh really yeah yeah i've yeah
um like in a shootout like well just
running are you
people shooting at you yeah because you
know
a lot of times a lot of times in the
projects
or even around surrounding areas if
someone's got beef with you you don't
know when they're coming
so so when you ever hear the terms about
having eyes behind your
behind your head right you don't know
when they're coming
you don't know how people are coming for
you and you don't know who
sometimes sometimes you don't know who a
a lot of times you know you see people
just run up on someone if
you watch any of this stuff you see on
the news right the person didn't call
them and say yo
i'ma come get you at four o'clock nah
nobody says that they just
go and if you happen to be there you
don't even know
the guy runs up on you and starts
shooting at you now
fun fact most people
who have guns can't shoot
this is a this is this is a huge it's a
fact
most people who have guns illegally
cannot shoot now doesn't mean you guys
got to come try to shoot me now to prove
a point
but you know but but you know what i'm
talking about most people they
because you know in order to shoot a gun
properly you have to take training to do
it right
right i mean this is not shooting a gun
properly
right it's not it's just not and uh most
people miss
point blank range like point like most
people
shoot you here and they kick back and
they'll miss
so yeah wow it's crazy
that's crazy but isn't it true that most
people that are in gangs that
that own guns i mean they're not i mean
people in gangs they're not
necessarily killers like they're not
just trying to go out and kill people
they're doing it
to protect themselves for the most part
right yeah the
the most part of it is just trying to
protect what's yours
you know yeah and not letting someone
else come in and try to step in
and take what's yours you know by all
means necessary you want to
protect what's yours yeah it's pretty
much
so